[Música]
[Aplausos]
les vengo a contar tres cosas sobre mi
primera hago xilografía grabado la
segunda
quiero aprender latín porque voy a
estudio del derecho y la tercera fui
mamá a los 14
sumado que todos se sorprenden más por
esta
y piensan en el siglo 21 en 2018 una
chica de 13 años embaraza teniendo
acceso a toda la información que hay a
los métodos anticonceptivos al internet
que estado la información del mundo no
es tan así no es tan así ahí estamos
esto es ccoo chamo
nada no se ve se ve grande pero no lo es
esa caja de zapatos que ven ahí en
nuestra posta tú hablas en una
habitación y se escucha en casi todas
las demás y cuál es el problema
cuando quisiera la matrona se escuchaba
todo todo todo todo todo si voy a pedir
un condón escuchado si el método
anticonceptivo se escuchaba y cuál es el
problema de que nos escuchen que les
molesta les moleste que queramos saber
de sexualidad les molesta que queramos
tener una vida sexual activa
es importante si es importante porque es
un pueblo chico si lo escucharon en la
posta lo saben todos
a los 13 me quedé embarazada
empecé a sentir ojos sobre mis ojos que
me miran todo lo que hacía y miran con
esta cara
pobrecita está embarazada y tiene 13
yo sé que estoy embarazada yo sé que
tengo 3 yo sé que va a ser difícil pero
si me lo dices me siento peor si me lo
dices me pongo más nerviosa si me lo
dices me asusto más
sería
no dejaba que me toquen porque cuando
uno está embarazada te vuelves un
carrito de supermercado porque un
carrito de supermercado uno al
supermercado empieza comprar sus cosas y
cuando va la gente pasando ven lo que
tienes dentro de si llevas por dulces y
lleva y verduras lo que lleves
pero 9 en el carro algunos han detenido
a ver el color de la manilla del carro
del que va al lado si tiene algo pegado
si tienen chile pegado sigue se
encuentra y te vuelves este carro la
mamá se vuelve secarlo no hay lo que
nadie lo nota pero tienen lo que está
dentro tienen que eso que está dentro de
propiedad pública que te pueden tocar
pueden ir a decir cuántos meses tienes
cuando nace es niño o es niña cómo le
vas a poner no quiero compartir esa
información con todo y creo que no todos
siempre queremos hacerlo
si vamos nace mi hijo yo tenía 14
uno es primero estuve en un hospital
patronas también pesadas la videncia
obstétrica que tenga la edad que tenga
pero en la adolescencia algo horrible te
miran y te dicen es tu culpa está acá
porque quieres si te duele no es mi
problema a mí no me dolía todavía por lo
menos
cambio hospital
en el hospital fue mejor
pero siguen mirándome con esta cara
pobrecita
hinchada pobrecita este que soy
pobrecita déjame hacer
nace mi hijo esas miradas que antes
miraban iwata mi estómago miran a mi
hijo miran como yo toma mi hijo como yo
le hablo a mi hijo todo
y empiezo a retraer
porque empiezan a cuestionarme
no lo puedes cargar así está mal se le
va a quebrar algo
no lo puedes dar solo pecho no va a
recibir las vitaminas que necesita
yo quiero estar dormir en una lejos de
ti quien más la madre cómo se te ocurre
estamos en el zulo hace frío
le puedes dar de probar comida antes de
los seis meses y estás estás
cuestionamientos que nos hacen a todos
yo sé que no le pasa solo las
adolescentes pero a mí ya me estaba
estaba enojada con esto trabajaban esta
situación
y esta presión es horrible y qué pasa
cuando uno basado en el fondo se empieza
achicar chica la chica de chica y
empiezo a checar y me siento pequeña
cada vez más pequeña más de lo que ella
soy por estatura mientras 54
y esas chicas las chicas las chicas es
tan pequeña tan pequeña tan pequeña tan
pequeña
hasta que explotó ya no me importa si te
molesta que yo le dé pecho a mi hijo
hasta los dos años y medio problema tuya
si le di de comer sopa los tres meses y
te molesto problema tuyo a mi hijo no lo
está pasando nada malo está bien está
creciendo bien es una inteligente
y empiezo a recuperar esta personalidad
que perdí cuando me hacía pequeña porque
mientras estás perdiendo es pedacitos de
ti
empezó a recuperar estos pedacitos a
tomarlos
un tema tan banal como la música yo
escuchaba rap hip hop o lo escucho y me
decían escucharemos esta música acerca
de tu hijo eso está tan ico
el satánico slap
pero bueno empezar a recuperar esto y
empieza a quitar una venta de los ojos
que yo no tenía idea que tenía puesta
que no sabía que tenía una venda en los
ojos empieza a ver que como yo hay madre
adolescente que como yo hay más gente
que no tiene información sexual porque
es un tabú porque no se habla porque si
lo hablas no hablas calladito con tu
pareja y si tiene más de una pareja
sexual queda escoba
los calladitos conmigo
violaciones mujeres violentadas que no
saben que lo están siendo porque es tan
normal si tu marido te grita no importa
a los hombres zonas y si te pegas en
escatrón vía 2 déjalo pasar después
pides algo a cambio una salida unas
flores un chocolate y ya déjalo pasar
los hombres son así si los hombres son
así porque las mujeres no está mal en
los dos casos pero se nota una
diferencia que sé que todas las notas
incesto
hombres que se creen con el derecho a
que porque un niño de su sangre tienen
que iniciarla en la vida sexual que es
su deber ellos están para eso no es así
no es así
enfermedades de transmisión sexual o no
saben lo que son o no conocen ejemplos o
si las conocen si saben algo y creen
tener un síntoma no van a la posta a
esta caja de zapatos
porque les da vergüenza porque si
alguien te escucha decir eso
wow
y empezamos a empiezo a cuestionarme
todo esto pensaba de pensar empecé en el
feminismo se empezó a hacer popular
empecé a ver cómo publicar en facebook
instagram y
tenía estas ideas pero no quedaban en
ideas que alguien debería hacer algo
podría ser algo pero no lo es
tengo idea y de ahí y de ahí no tenía
ideas
hasta que a principios de año se nos
presenta la oportunidad de presentar un
proyecto con unas amigas tomamos la
opción de sexualidad gracias al
comentario un profesor me dice tú
tuviste un hijo a los 14 porque eso
empieza a retroceder me di cuenta que
jamás hable abiertamente de sexualidad
jamás hice preguntas
los otros niños deben estar en la misma
situación deben tener preguntas que no
están siendo contestadas
necesitamos contestarlas hagamos un
proyecto en el que se enseña desde el
primero básico seis años hasta cuarto
medio dieciocho subiendo de nivel con la
edad los niños
enseñémosles que tienen los penes en la
vagina desde que nacieron que las niñas
les van a crecer los pechos
enséñame lo que esto es normal que no
tienen por qué esconder en nuestro
cuerpo ustedes con en su cuerpo por ser
mujeres por ser hombre niegan que lo son
no cierto entonces por qué por qué
hacerlo por qué ponerle un nombre
extraño al pene a la vagina a los pechos
enseñémosles esto vayamos escalando
el texto básico recuerdo 12 años más o
menos recuerdo un día estar sentada
grabando un cortometraje con las amigas
sobre sexualidad y dejé el vídeo al
estuche que no tenía un dildo y condones
para la demostración
y las niñas lo abren y beben y empiezan
a ver los condones dicen que esto
qué es esto tienen 12 años que me
embaracé los 13
tuve que contarle tenemos métodos
anticonceptivos a la rápida que tenía
que ir corriendo que las otra vez
sigamos en el proyecto me decía un poco
el pedo contaba con un programa de radio
pero tiene escuchar la radio al menos
escuchamos nos escucha 23 personas a las
que no les interesa
pero igual es necesario que hagan las
preguntas anónimamente para eso el
programa
veamos cómo
recuerdo que cuando quise hacer una
pregunta de sexualidad no la hice porque
pensaba que era tonta porque pensaba que
el profesor me podía retratar
s niños pueden sentir esto también
tejemos alguien de los niños mayores
qué
los representes que tome esa pregunta y
la lleva frente al especialista o frente
al profesor
este niño puede ser representado y su
duda se ha contactado ya perfect
que necesitamos necesitamos el permiso
para entrar esos colegios en mi colegio
en mi comuna hay dos colegios grandes
siempre kinder hasta cuarto medio y de
pre kinder hasta el segundo medio y
entre el camino entre estos dos colegios
que es una infinidad
es una infinidad hay un montón de
pequeñas escuelas que más de 20 alumnos
no tienen
necesito el permiso para entrenar esos
colegios
esperamos una reunión con el director de
educación municipal me da permiso para
entrar a la oficina de la mujer que
también estaba en ese reunión el
representante me dice también me asomo
en ese tema de salud tenía como un
instituto por lo siento así y me dice de
pollo de los materiales para hacer estas
charlas más entretenidas los niños se
van a aburrir se aburren cuando le
hablan de sexualidad de biología de
químicas
hagámoslo así y así fue como surgió
nuestro nuestro proyecto que arranca en
2019 marzo junto con el colegio
y les voy a estar terminando les voy a
dejar esta invitación antes de irme
limitaciones acepta una pregunta a
cuestionarse una sola cosa
que existió antes la sociedad la
sexualidad la sexualidad sin sexualidad
no estaríamos aquí
si la sexualidad existió antes que la
sociedad en qué momento se convirtió en
un tabú en qué momento algo tan natural
algo tan primitivo por así decirlo un
instinto de reproducción se volvió un
tabú en qué momento muchas gracias
[Aplausos]